out and safe
ukraine says all women children and the
elderly have been evacuated from the as
of stall steel
plants for months they sheltered in
underground bunkers while ukrainian
fighters from the azov battalion
attempted to prevent russian soldiers
from completely taking over the port
city
president zielenski repeatedly called on
the united nations to help lead
civilians to safety through humanitarian
corridors
i want to thank the teams of the
international committee of the red cross
and the united nations for helping us
carry out the first phase of the
azerstall plant evacuation mission we
managed to save more than 300 people
women and children
russia agreed to a number of ceasefires
to facilitate evacuations both kiev and
moscow repeatedly accused one another of
violating the truce
hundreds of civilians were eventually
evacuated in multiple operations led by
the united nations
taken to a nearby village away from the
shelling
but with the fate of ukrainian fighters
still in the steel works it's unclear if
president vladimir putin will be able to
declare victory mario pole in time for
may 9th a day where russia celebrates
the soviet union's world war ii victory
over the nazis assad beg al-jazeera
woman